[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock the cost of living crisis is
about to get even worse energy bills are
going up by several hundred pounds a
year for the average household pushing
more families into fuel poverty can the
government get a grip on soaring prices
before it's too late from the pork pie
plot to the cream tea coo more letters
from tory mps who want to get rid of the
pm and then after nine a powerful report
from our special correspondent alex
crawford
which you really don't want to miss
on the children on the front line of a
humanitarian disaster in afghanistan
it's thursday the 3rd of february
cost of living crisis millions facing a
rise of hundreds of pounds a year on
their energy bills with a massive price
coup hike at price cap height forgive me
expected today
i'm in newman east london where families
already struggling to pay their bills
wait to see what the chancellor plans to
do to cope with the soaring cost of
living
growing pressure on boris johnson to
quit from his own mps as three more
submit no confidence letters
i'm in beijing where the chinese and
russian foreign ministers are holding
talks today on the crisis in ukraine
welcoming the world again new zealand's
border will open in stages from the end
of the month
i am yours
you are mine
you are what you are
you make it hard
streaming controversy crosby steals and
nash joined the artists who pulled their
music from spotify
also to come on the programme this
morning the sleep secrets of an olympic
champion will speak to gold medal winner
greg rutherford on why sleep is his
superpower
why would i betray you we all have our
secrets
we just didn't get to yours yet
goodness shake and not stare daniel
craig's final outing as bond among the
favourites as the bafta nominees are
announced later on today
[Music]
good morning everybody it's thought that
around a quarter of households will be
pushed into fuel poverty with the price
cap expected to go up by 51
that means bills of more than
hundred pounds compared to the current
cap
of one thousand two hundred and seventy
seven pounds a year and helen ann has
more
it's on streets like these where rising
bills really bite
abdul spends as much spare time as he
has delivering food parcels to people in
bradford
you got your milk you've got your bread
everything in there
he says the number of calls have nearly
doubled since this time last year even
as we drive around they keep coming i
mean i'm getting called through nine ten
o'clock in the evening people have just
got nothing in their fridges they say
buy some food
um or hit their house up
they have no choice
there we go ma
keller
he knows a hike in energy bills will be
crippling to people like emma but the
price cap in place to protect people is
set to rise by as much as 50 percent
emma can't afford to heat the house
often when she does it doesn't last long
it stays warm for about 10-15 minutes
and then that's it
even if we're under quilt and we have
hot water bottle it's still cold and we
just sit there shaking and everything
rising bills will affect millions of us
but they'll bite the hardest for those
with the fewest choices
and that includes the option to move on
embarking in dagenham there aren't
enough permanent homes aleph jane and
her family are stuck here while they
wait for one you can see
mould the dump and cold are so bad the
walls literally drip with condensation
mold grows everywhere i did just to
mention clean up on
saturday warming this place is expensive
and she's worried
this whole month
i've i've struggled i've put in whatever
i can afford and that could be like two
pounds to four pounds
to
highest would be 10 or 15 pounds but
then that would mean i'll have to take
something off my budget so one less
thing for the kids
millions of households could soon face
energy bills of around 2000 pounds a
year whether that much can be managed
depends a lot on who you are and where
you live
helen and smith sky news
well sent arsenal to east london which
has the highest rate of fuel poverty in
england with us now
oh my goodness me these poor people they
must be terrified about what's going to
be said later on today
i think they are going to be very much
okay helena was right there often it
does depend on geography it depends on
the type of house you're living in the
size of your household and here in new
and they do have the highest rate of
fuel poverty in england that translates
to about a fifth of households some 23
and a half thousand families who are
struggling to heat their homes already
with this price cap rising it could end
up being that by april as soon as april
their bills could rise in excess of
perhaps 1 500 pounds going up to maybe 2
000 pounds and that's really going to
affect people on those standard variable
tariffs but also people who are on
prepaid meters and we know that for
people that tend to be on prepaid meters
perhaps in the past they have had
problems and struggled to pay their
electricity bills and energy bills in
the past and therefore perhaps changing
supply or changing what tariffs they're
on isn't going to be that much of a of a
help for them and of course more people
are working from home those colder
winters of course we are consistently
reminded of the cost that it takes to
warm our homes many people also fear
that this limit whilst it is called a
limit increasingly energy suppliers are
seeing that as a target price so their
bills could be around that price it
could be lower than that energy cap but
it could also be higher and that is very
much the fear for people here they are
going to be waiting with baited breath
to see what the chancellor can offer
them to ease that burden okay
thank you tamara's here when will we
hear from the chancellor we're here at
the chu from the chancellor at 11 which
is the time that the regulator will
announce what the price cap is expected
to be knocking on for 2 000 pounds over
this period he will stand up in the
commons and announce the support that
the government is offering which we
understand is going to be a discount for
all households of around 200 pounds
covered by government loans to the
energy companies which will have to be
paid back at some stage possibly on our
bills and we think that there's another
rabbit coming out of the hat as well to
be announced either in the commons or at
a press conference we understand the
chancellor is doing afterwards and
there's talk in the newspapers today of
people getting a rebate on their council
tax for people whose properties are in
the lowest bands which would add another
couple of hundred pounds so these are
big interventions from a chancellor
who's been reluctant to spend money who
says that we you know we need to now um
pull the purse strings back after covid
but the government know that this is a
really serious cost of living squeeze
they need a big intervention in order to
make sure that people aren't going to be
facing a really difficult time over the
next few months okay um tomorrow's take
of course at nine o'clock uh meantime
more letters handed in to the 1922
committee just to explain to our viewers
what that means drip of letters from
tory mps calling on the prime minister
to resign if that number of letters hits
54 which is 15 of conservative mps then
there is a vote of confidence in boris
johnson we saw three yesterday tobias
elwood on our program said that he now
thinks the prime minister shouldn't
carry on he sent in a letter and then
two other mps we heard from also
yesterday uh both from devon which is
why it's being dubbed in a newspaper um
the uh the cream coup cream
based on two letters perhaps a bit of a
stretch but this is one of them anthony
magnull from tot ness he said standards
in public life matter at this time i can
no longer support the pm his actions and
mistruths are overshadowing the
extraordinary work of so many excellent
ministers and colleagues i have
submitted a letter of no confidence
we also heard later in the day from gary
streeter mp for south west devon he said
i cannot reconcile the pain and
sacrifice of the vast majority of the
british public during lockdown with the
attitude and activities of those working
in downing street accordingly i have now
submitted a letter seeking a motion of
confidence in the prime minister i have
not come to this decision lightly it is
not my intention to say any more about
this matter i think what's interesting
kay is these mps appear to be
disconnected from each other this is not
a one faction this is not like with
theresa may when it was obvious that the
hardcore brexiteer faction wanted to get
rid of her these are people gary
streeter elected in 1992 anthony magnol
elected in 2019 they on they don't seem
to be coordinated although perhaps they
are and we don't know about it but that
will what really worry downing street
this is these are shots coming out of
nowhere and it could be that at some
point soon we do hit that 54 threshold
okay tomorrow for now tomorrow's take as
i said at nine o'clock thank you uh
where's the minister we're going to have
the minister on the programme uh in the
next hour so stay tuned for more on that
and the story of rising energy costs is
dominating the front pages this morning
the financial times reports that in
cooperation with the bank of england the
chancellor rishi sunak will announce a
package of measures aimed at curbing
inflation and averting a cost of living
crisis
a telegraph describes mr sunak as
splashing out on the multi-billion pound
package the mail says the heat is now on
the chancellor with bills expecting to
rise by 650 pounds for some households
the mirror calls it d-day on price's
agony while the times his council tax
rebates could be on the cards in an
attempt to ease some of the pain but the
eye speaks to sources who believe it
hasn't been properly funded and lacks
ambition
more on the cost of living crisis now
rising energy bills soaring inflation
and higher interest rates the
confederation of british industry the
cbi says the uk is caught in a trap of
low growth and high taxes the cbi
director general tony yanka is with us
now hello to mr danke thank you so much
for taking the time to join us on the
program this morning what a mess it is
for so many families up and down the
country um
what do we need to hear do you think
from the chancellor later on today and
what advice can you give to people
well look if the trails are to be
believed the chancellor is going to take
some action to smooth this cliff edge of
rising energy bills uh and that's good
news so first and foremost i think the
government taking action is good news we
hear that actually the method they may
choose to deal with this is to put loans
uh on the books of energy companies i'm
not sure that's the right way forward
but let's find out when the detail comes
i think my real concern and i think
everybody's real concern is that this
rise in gas prices in energy bills is
not just going to be a one-off right we
are probably looking at two or three
years worth of very high energy bills
and whilst our economy is growing at the
moment coming back from uh the crisis uh
the economy is set to really fall in
terms of growth over the next two or
three years so
i'm afraid we may be talking on this
program about energy prices for two or
three years
today it's great that we're tackling you
know the chancellor i hope will grasp
the nettle but this could be an issue
for us for the next few years and my
question is really whether or not the
economy is going to grow fast enough
after this year for everybody to have
the wage growth they need to cope with
higher bills
yeah because the growth forecasts i
think are between 1.3 and 1.7 percent
something like that uh compared to past
levels of levels of what two to two and
uh two to two and a half so that's right
i mean this year we we should grow at
six percent you know this is the if you
remember people talk about a v-shaped
recovery right this is the way back up
we should grow at six percent but
already next year that drops to two and
then it drops to 1.3
so we may be kicking the can down the
road to deal with the uh energy crisis
uh the way we're dealing with it now
don't get me wrong smoothing that cliff
edge is critical and you know well done
to the government for tackling it uh
let's see the detail but i think this is
a much more profound problem or how
britain is going to grow its economy and
grow wages in the next three to five
years
uh you said the economy cannot sustain
i'm quoting you ever increasing taxes
who would have said that about a
conservative government
no i think that's right look this the
government's in a tough spot now
conservative thinkers are in a tough
spot because of course the conservatives
believe in low taxes but they also
believe in tight public spending
and i think we are stuck in this trap
really where on the one hand the public
spending pressure on things like the
health service is great so nobody wants
to cut spending taxes are already about
to go up to their highest in 70 years so
what's the way out of that the only way
out of that to avoid either austerity or
even higher taxes is to grow the economy
faster and yet we are forecast to grow
the economy slower than britain usually
does so we need to do better than that
what did you make of yesterday's
leveling up announcements by mr
yeah look i think the leveling up white
paper yesterday did a couple of things
finally one is they they basically
defined leveling up they said here are
the 12 things leveling up will achieve
and you know hold us accountable for the
targets by 2030. that's really welcome
they put in place a lot of good
foundations to make sure that money
spent by government isn't concentrated
only in the southeast that's good
they're trying to strengthen the role of
mayors and have mayors
as major figures in driving local
economies and that's good what we don't
yet have is a plan for how we're going
to get around the country lots of
private sector growth outside the well
familiar uh spaces and cities in our
country and so that's the bit i'm
looking forward to working with michael
gove and his colleagues on over the
coming months because to be honest if it
doesn't turn into you know better firms
better jobs and better wages then people
will turn around and say what was it all
about
would you like to swap roles with the
chancellor at the moment
no look the chancellor has a very tough
job and i think he's trying to balance
uh quite a lot of things i think he's
doing a good job
in that regard it's a big day for him
but to be honest it's a big day really
for everybody in the country who i think
are trying to manage cost of living uh
crisis uh and we're incred i know
they're talking to business leaders
they're incredibly attuned uh to
affordability to wage pressures to cost
pressures and so i think all of us are
confronting a cost of living squeeze in
this quarter in particular and we need
to think hard to make sure look if it's
going to be a bumpy quarter what we
can't have is a bumpy decade and we need
to think about how we're going to grow
the economy so that we don't find
ourselves in this pickle
every year for the next five years
good to talk to you thanks for taking
the time as i said thank you
we know that so many of you are
struggling at the moment already with
your energy bills and uh that increase
is coming i'm afraid we'll be going to
be talking to some of the energy
companies during the program to see what
if anything they can do to try to help
you something like one in four
households are going to find themselves
in fuel poverty um depending on what the
increase will be so we'll talk about
that throughout the course of the
programme today and the
chancellor making his announcement at 11
o'clock which of course we'll cover here
on sky this hour though we're going to
be talking in more detail about the cost
of energy on everyone's mind of course
and we'll speak to the founder as i said
of a company offering its customers a
green alternative is it cheaper
vaccine mandate u-turn will speak to a
physio student refusing to get jabbed as
the government considers scrapping
mandatory covey jabs for nhs staff
and then shortly after h the shadow
chief secretary to the treasury pat
mcfadden will be here to give us his
take on those rising energy prices
before that though the united states and
france have agreed to coordinate their
response to russia's military buildup on
the ukrainian border it comes as
president biden pledged to deploy an
extra 3 000 troops to support nato
countries in eastern europe the move
comes amid growing tensions with russia
which has massed more than a hundred
thousand troops on the border with
ukraine the pentagon says the u.s
deployment is a preventative measure
these are not permanent moves
they are moves designed to respond to
the current security environment
moreover
these forces are not going to fight in
ukraine
they're going to ensure the robust
defense
of our nato allies
today the russian foreign minister is in
beijing for talks with his chinese
counterpart um tom is standing by in
beijing for us um hello to you tom how
do we envisage that going
morning k yeah well today is really a
curtain raiser for the big meeting which
is going to happen tomorrow when
president xi jinping will welcome
president vladimir putin he's called him
his best friend in the past xi jinping
hasn't met another world leader over the
last two years because of the covet
situation and staying in china and
putin's going to be the first and they
have got incredibly close together
chinese state media described them as
standing back to back against their
opponents specifically in relation to
this crisis in ukraine and china has
been supporting russia uh it voiced its
support for russia's concern over nato
and the u.s it's been working at the
united nations security council
to stop action happening then i think we
can expect some specifics from this
meeting tomorrow especially in terms of
trade deals gas deals uh things like
that president putin was writing in
xinhua which is chinese state media here
uh he had an op-ed there and he listed a
couple of things that he was looking
forward to including that gas deal which
could be useful for russia if gas
supplies to europe are shut off it's
another source of revenue in the event
of a conflict with ukraine he also said
they're working together on creating
mechanisms to offset the negative impact
of unilateral sanctions
so that threat of sanctions china and
russia are already working together to
try and mitigate that so they are very
close indeed now some people have
suggested there might be an olympic
truce that we won't see any conflict in
ukraine while the winter olympics are
happening here in beijing they open
tomorrow night and the idea that perhaps
president xi has asked president putin
to hold off and not spoil his parade but
on the other hand it's worth thinking
back to 2008 the summer olympics also
here in beijing the evening of the
opening ceremony is when we got the
first reports of russian troops moving
into georgia so it's not a given that
something won't happen over the next two
weeks despite that burgeoning friendship
between presidents putin and xi
okay thank you thanks a lot
something happening on the uh programme
next week to tell you about 9 00 a.m
next monday morning 7th of february the
education secretary nadim zahawi will be
here to answer all of your questions you
can send them to us via twitter or email
your questions or send us a video clip
of your questions you can email ask the
education secretary at sky dot uk so
many of you have already sifting through
them as we speak and we will be putting
some of your questions to the education
secretary on monday morning at nine
o'clock
the british government has said it won't
intervene after northern ireland's
agriculture minister announced a halt to
checks on goods entering the country
from the rest of the uk
the move appears to defy trading rules
which were implemented after the uk left
the european union our senior island
correspondent david blevins has more
on the surface this is about trade
whether or not checks should continue to
be carried out between great britain and
northern ireland as agreed by the eu and
british government as part of the wider
brexit deal but in reality it's about
politics because the border in the rhc
designed to avoid a border on this
island has raised unionist fears about
northern ireland's place in the united
kingdom so it's a unionist minister who
acted unilaterally to order an end to
those checks much to the fury of other
parties in what's supposed to be a
power-sharing government at stormont the
irish government says it's a breach of
international law the british government
says it's not getting involved but how
can it avoid getting involved because
this puts huge pressure on the devolved
government at stormont we're just three
months from an election here and i think
we're witnessing the beginning of the
end of this administration
new zealand has announced plans to
reopen its borders in stages although it
will be many months before the country
is open to everybody here's siobhan
so finally a thought in what have been
some of the toughest coronavirus border
restrictions in the world new zealand
laying out its five steps to reopening
and this is the timetable they're going
to be working to so from the 27th of
february vaccinated new zealanders in
australia will be able to come back
quarantine free from the 13th of march
vaccinated new zealanders around the
world can return they're also looking to
open up to some skilled workers then in
april they'll look to welcome around 5
000 international students in july
non-citizens from countries which you
should get a visa waiver who are
vaccinated can start to visit and then
in october they hope to reopen to the
rest of the world now this is important
you have to be vaccinated otherwise you
would still have to quarantine but this
is going to be a huge step forward for
new zealanders who have been stuck
outside the country some not seeing
their families for two years but i think
it's also an important step because it
shows us where we are with coronavirus
globally at the beginning when new
zealand brought in these really tough
restrictions it was really seen as
keeping people safe but as coronavirus
has become endemic in an increasing
number of countries many people inside
new zealand are criticizing its
government for being out of step with
the rest of the world
and we're also um just hearing within
the last few moments we've heard from
the swedish prime minister via the
reuters news agency
saying
that it does look as though the pandemic
in sweden is heading to a new phase
and the latest on that is that
restrictions that are presently in place
will be lifted when they come to an end
at the end of the week next week so
it's becoming time to remove
restrictions is what the swedish prime
minister has said could
life be getting back to normal whisper
it quietly but it's heading in that
direction
latest covert data in the uk for today
showing the highest number of daily
deaths though in almost a year
we've had more than 88 000 new cases of
coronavirus confirmed in the uk in the
last 24-hour period another 534 deaths
recorded the highest number since last
february that takes the total number of
deaths within 28 days of a positive test
to 157
409. the uk health security agency said
the number of deaths is high because the
data includes what it calls a backlog of
recent fatalities
meantime the mayor of london sadiq khan
says he has put the metropolitan police
commissioner dame cressida dick
unnoticed on notice after evidence of
sexist racist and homophobic behavior
among officers his comments came after a
90-minute meeting with the commissioner
however any decision to dismiss her
would have to be made by the home
secretary priti patel
suffering two or more chronic health
problems in midlife more than doubles
the risk of dementia a study found
illnesses such as heart disease high
blood pressure and diabetes could all
have an impact especially if developed
at a younger age
ryanair has been ranked the worst
short-haul airline by customers for
dealing with refunds during the pandemic
one in five passengers surveyed by the
consumer group which said it took more
than a month to get a refund
british airways was voted second lowest
for refund satisfaction jet2.com was
ranked the best
it's claimed poisoned cocaine has killed
20 people and made 74 others seriously
ill in argentina according to health
officials police say a dozen people had
been arrested after the batch was found
to be sold in a poor neighborhood of
buenos aires
around a thousand u.s officials struck
down with a mysterious illness known as
havana syndrome could have been targeted
by
electromagnetic energy pulses a report
by us intelligence experts believes this
could explain the ear pain vertigo and
other symptoms first reported by embassy
staff in the cuban capital in 2016.
airlines cancelled hundreds of flights
on wednesday as a major winter storm
battered parts of mid-america with
states as far south as new mexico
issuing warnings the forecast comes
nearly a year after a catastrophic
winter storm devastated the texas power
grid causing hundreds of deaths
back to beijing for you now where a
belgian skeleton racer has been freed
from isolation after a tearful plea for
help
kim mailman's was originally told she
could leave her quarantine hotel after
three days after she tested positive for
kobe but yesterday rather than return
her to the olympic village the 25 year
old was taken to a different facility
for another week of isolation
i'm supposed to stay here
for
um another seven days with two pcrs a
day and no contact with anybody else we
are not even sure i will ever be allowed
to return to the village
and obviously this is very hard for me
well after posting that emotional video
on instagram the international olympic
committee intervened and kim has now
been moved to a single room in the
village
i am now in a wing that's just isolation
but at least i'm back in the village i
feel safe and
i'll be able to train a little better
here
what a difference today makes now a
popular podcaster joe rogan is
continuing to face a backlash after
being accused of spreading
misinformation about covid19 and
vaccines neil young and joni mitchell
are among the artists who pulled their
music from the platform's spotify in
protest
[Music]
crosby stills and nash have joined their
fellow musicians in boycotting the
musical
streaming service in a joint statement
they said we support neil and we agree
with him that there is dangerous
disinformation being aired on spotify's
joe rogan podcast while we always value
alternate points of view knowingly
spreading disinformation during this
global pandemic has deadly consequences
until real action is taken to show that
a concern for humanity must be balanced
with commerce we don't want our music or
the music we made together to be on the
same platform
is now the time when i tell you i've
never heard of that band i know
i know
uh seriously darren my director saying
he's never heard of them either so there
you go it's that time of year again the
nominees for this year's bafta awards
will be announced later on today
what little lady made these
i did sir
[Music]
oh it's not very nice the power of the
dog and west side story are among the
favorites tipped to receive multiple
awards at the ceremony the shortlist for
this year's rising star prize has
already been announced nominees include
no time to dies lashna lynch and west
side stories ariana debose the
categories the only one at the ceremony
voted for by the public do you have a
favor i've not seen my side's story yet
but apparently it's fantastic and piers
is telling me my everybody's talking to
me this morning um yeah apparently it is
very good it's stephen spielberg isn't
it piers i think i'm writing saying that
so um let me know if you've seen it
perhaps you'd like to tweet me uh
directly at k burley quick look at the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
staying mostly mild today but colder air
following a rain band into the northwest
will spread to all parts by tomorrow
morning
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
if we couldn't love her anymore the
duchess of cambridge kate middleton has
been showing off her rugby skills after
becoming patron of the rugby football
league and the rugby football union most
impressive
her royal highness quite literally
living up to her name as she's hoisted
into the air there kate is a well-known
rugby fan and judging by this display
she might be spending less time watching
in the grandstand and perhaps
more time playing on the field the role
was previously held by
prince harry
that'll teach him and let's have a look
at some of the uh pictures that we've
found in the papers for you today the
times features two british women having
broken the record for the fastest female
pair to row across the atlantic great
photograph jessica oliver
charlotte harris had rode before neither
of them actually had rode before
starting the 3 000 mile trip but wiped
five days off the record if you want
something done ask a woman if you want
it really done ask two now it was
groundhog day yesterday again the
guardian with this shot of the
136th annual event in pennsylvania where
phil the groundhog saw his own
shadow meaning a prediction of another
six
weeks of winter
trying to remember is it pensacola phil
can't remember and have you ever been
this hungry a buzzard and a red kite
posed
in the telegraph
as they fight over dinner in wiltshire
it took the photographer 20 hours to get
the shot i think you'll agree with us
that it was absolutely well worth it not
quite sure which one won maybe they
shared coming up energy bills are
expected to rise by hundreds of pounds
we'll speak to a supplier very shortly
stated
[Music]
hello again everybody our top stories
for you on the breakfast programme this
thursday morning the energy regulator
off gem is expected to announce a new
price cap this morning that will
increase household bills by hundreds of
pounds
three more conservative mps have
revealed that they have submitted
letters of no confidence in batman boris
johnson in the last 24 hours
and the united states and france have
agreed to coordinate their response to
russia's military buildup on the
ukrainian border while the chinese and
russian foreign ministers are in beijing
to discuss the ongoing crisis
more on our top story in our energy
prices are set to rise significantly for
millions of households who are already
facing soaring bills the regulator ofgem
will announce the new energy price cap
later on this morning the director
general of the confederation of british
industry the cbi says today's
announcement
won't be the last
my real concern and i think everybody's
real concern is that this rise in uh gas
prices in energy bills is not just going
to be a one-off right we are probably
looking at two or three years worth of
very high energy bills
and whilst our economy is growing at the
moment coming back from uh the crisis uh
the economy is set to really fall in
terms of growth over the next two or
three years we may be kicking the canned
on the road to deal with the energy
crisis uh the way we're dealing with it
now don't get me wrong smoothing that
cliff edge is critical and you know well
done to the government for tackling it
uh let's see the detail but i think this
is a much more profound problem for how
britain is going to grow its economy and
grow wages in the next three to five
years
tamara's here tomorrow um so what what's
happening today we're going to hear from
the chancellor that's right at 11
o'clock we'll get the announcement from
ofgem the regulator of what the price
rise the price cap will be on energy
bills how much they could rise to we
expect that to be 600 pounds per
household or thereabouts an absolutely
huge rise
shortly after that we will hear from the
chancellor in the house of commons he
will set out what support the government
is offering families to help with that
we expect that's going to be a discount
of around 200 pounds for everyone you
remember he's talking you've been
talking for weeks about targeting
support at the poorest we expect this is
actually going to be for all households
to be funded by billions of pounds the
government will loan to energy companies
now that will be good as a one-off but
as tony danker of the cbi was saying we
expect that it won't be a one-off
because energy bills could stay very
high for the next two to three years or
beyond because global gas prices may
well remain high so what's the chance
they're going to do then because the
energy companies will have to pay those
loans back then we will also get a
downing street press conference from
rishi sunak at five o'clock today and we
expect he has another rabbit in his hat
as well there's a lot of talk in the
papers today about people getting a
rebate on their council tax if they live
in properties in the lowest bands a b
and c we haven't seen any detail of that
yet but that would help people on low
incomes as well it won't cover the whole
price rise but they're clearly getting
the big guns out aware that people are
going to be really struggling over the
next few months but how is it going how
is it going to be paid for in the long
term is of course a big question um and
also something on the prime minister's
mind today while all of this is going on
is whether or not he's still going to
keep his job any time soon that's right
we've seen an interesting drip drip of
tory mps sending in letters calling for
him to resign we had three yesterday
tobias elwood former defence minister on
our programme he's been quite critical
but said he wants the prime minister to
go now he sent in his letter then we had
two more mps yesterday seemingly
disconnected from each other both devon
mps which is why it's being called the
the cream tea coup we had um one called
anthony magnull uh from top ness uh he
he said uh he sent it in a letter and
tweeted that he could no longer support
the prime minister and gary streeter
another devon mp so the question is is
this coordinated
so far we don't think it is we think
this is mps soul-searching and just
coming to the same conclusion they don't
seem to be a faction or a clique
connected to each other and that will
really worry downing street that uh
these shots could come out of army men
though aren't they
well gary streeter and anthony magnol i
don't think are but tobias elwood has
been very critical of the government on
defense and foreign policy certainly but
where the next letter is coming from you
know you're hearing from quiet mps who
don't normally talk to all the tv
studios suddenly putting their letters
in and
we don't simply don't know nobody knows
because this is a secret process how
close we are to the 54 letters that's 15
of tory mps which would trigger a
no-confidence vote in boris johnson yeah
there's some suggestions that downey
street are braced for it happening let
the record state that we are 40 minutes
into the show and we have not mentioned
sue gray once
a record indeed we'll see you at nine
o'clock thank you let's get a
perspective on the energy crisis um here
we go from one of the suppliers joining
us is the founder of the green energy
company ecotricity and that's dale vince
hi dale it's good to see you this
morning thanks very much indeed for
joining us what a challenging day for
everybody including you guys
yeah it's been a challenging five or six
months really you know the energy crisis
began in august and so far the
government have done nothing except hold
to the retail price cap while letting
wholesale prices go through the roof and
they've bankrupted 50 of the suppliers
in the market what we'll see today is
far too little and far too late and for
not long enough as the cbi guy said this
crisis will continue for three years
200 pounds is one-third of the price
rise that will be announced today for
one-third of the time that the problem
will endure it's tackling one tenth of
the problem it's a sticking plaster and
to lend the money to energy companies to
lend the money to customers honestly
it's a joke
um i'm looking at the figures suggesting
the price cap will rise fifty fifty five
zero percent what's that gonna mean for
your customers
um we're not a price capped company so
it's different for our customers but for
millions of people around the country
it's just gonna make
well energy bills unaffordable there are
plenty of people probably about four
million people already in energy poverty
that figure is set to go to six or seven
it's only surpassed by the number of
people in food poverty because national
insurance rises kick in in april as well
that's another 12 billion but look the
thing that doesn't get talked about is
the government talks about high energy
prices and and how they want to do
something about it what they're going to
announce today is not going to solve
that problem but the government takes 9
billion pounds every year from our
energy bills by way of tax be 80 and 5
stealth taxes if they want to solve this
problem properly they should stop taxing
energy or have a windfall tax on the
north sea sector that have made 20
billion pounds this winter through these
crazy wholesale prices
yeah although the prime minister i think
has ruled that out at least for now what
about energy independence which is
something that you've talked about
previously what is that
that's the proper long-term answer to
this problem so
we're in this situation because we're
dependent on fossil fuels but we're also
dependent on international markets to
set the price of fossil fuels so one of
the scandals of the energy crisis is 50
of our gas comes from the north sea and
yet we're paying 10 times more for it
than we used to because of global prices
so we have two dependencies one is on
fossil fuels and the other is on global
markets energy independence is about
making our own energy electricity and
gas here in britain from the wind and
the sun we can make gas from grass and
we can be completely independent of
foreign fossil fuel markets and
pre-crisis we spent 50 billion pounds a
year
bringing fossil fuels to our country
just to burn them if we spent that
budget for two or three years we could
make all of the energy we need from
renewable energy we would never have
rising energy bills again because
renewable energy doesn't go up in price
we could solve fuel poverty and really
strengthen our economy it's just time
that we did at times we stopped using
fossil fuels and broke away from global
markets set the price of our energy
bills
but is green energy expensive to start
with
no it's the cheapest form of new energy
that we can build
um so why do we have the myth that it's
it's much more expensive than burning
fossil fuels which is why we do it
i don't know because you know right now
offshore wind for example has no public
money no support at all onshore solar
has no public money at all nuclear is
costing a fortune in in subsidies that
are added to our energy bills um i don't
know
certainly there's a faction in the
conservative party that are against
green energy and green measures and and
climate change and that kind of stuff
and they like to talk up the cost of
green energy but it is a myth as you say
what's your advice to people who are
watching at home anxiously waiting for
what this price cap is going to be and
already thinking i can't heat the house
as it is or the flat or whatever
i think it's a real problem i mean there
are no easy answers price cap tariffs
are the cheapest energy that you can
find and they're still too expensive we
need the government to do something
actually do something not offer to lend
us money so that we can lend it to
customers who have to pay it back later
what good is that they need to stop
taxing energy bills 300 pounds every
year is a government tax on our energy
bills they should give that back
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed for the update much appreciated
thank you
thank you
thanks a lot i'm just um to let you know
that you've probably seen in the paper
this morning that there were four jets
russian jets that were headed off by the
raf
yesterday afternoon they didn't get into
british airspace but they certainly
headed in this direction what were they
up to um and what's going to happen next
with ukraine we're going to be talking
about that with lord danette coming up
shortly
before that though have a look at this
seemed like a good game chasing some
wild geese
there we go but it landed watson the
golden retriever
in very cold water
oh what was he doing during the chase
watson went through the ice of a frozen
pond in colorado a firefighter came to
the rescue and managed to get both the
dog and himself out of the freezing
water watson seemed happy
he doesn't look that happy to me
there you go did you know that dogs
shake from their heads backwards you
ever seen the slo-mo pictures of dogs
shaking if you haven't have a look on
youtube it's brilliant anyway wagging
tale back with owner can i chase them
again mom no you can't on your lead um
also have a look at this a bit of a rao
has uh erupted over this these pictures
show divers off the coast of newport
harbor in rhode island where researchers
think they might have found the final
resting place of hms endeavour the ship
of british explorer captain james cook
after a 22-year search operation the
australian national maritime museum
insists that this is the right site
but researchers in the u.s say the data
is disputable
watch this space we might feature that
on the program next week we'll have a
look into that for you and see what else
we can find out
we'll speak to a physio student as well
this hour refusing to get jabbed as the
government considers scrapping mandatory
jabs for nhs staff if you've got a view
on that it really does divide opinion
you can tweet us directly if you would
like to at k burley see in a second
[Music]
hello everybody how's your thursday
morning going let me tell you about the
government considering scrapping
controversial mandatory jobs for nhs
staff with a plan now under review but
it's left many nhs workers unsure if
they'll lose their jobs if they don't
get vaccinated joining us now is mariah
banson a physio student who has decided
not to get the coveted vaccine hi mariah
thank you for joining us first of all
why don't you want the vaccine
um well there's many reasons why i don't
want the vaccine i think there isn't
enough data for myself so far to get it
also i did an antibody test myself so i
know that i've got all the antibodies to
protect myself um so after you know
considering all the information i've had
i've decided that for me it's probably
not the best
best
thing to do right now
what about other people that you come
into contact with do we not have a
social responsibility to look after all
of us
yeah 100 i do believe that especially as
healthcare workers and we're we are
taught that um but we're also taught
that we know everyone has the right to
choose and there's body body and you
know it's our bodies and that we need to
make a decision for ourselves um for
myself if i i love people i love health
care and i really love helping people
and if i felt like i was a harm to them
you know i wouldn't do it but knowing
that i've got antibodies
knowing that i know i'm healthy and that
i'm testing and i'm wearing ppe i don't
really see how i would be that much harm
to people um in in the healthcare
setting
but you you could am i right in saying
you could actually pass on covid19 to
someone else if you're not vaccinated is
that not right well it's the same as
vaccinated people you know um in my
class there's probably two of us are not
vaccinated and the rest are vaccinated
every single one of them last time had
covered and they were on placements
where me and my other colleagues who
were not vaccinated we didn't get
covered so for me um when when i was
looking at that and thinking well
they've all got covered they all could
pass it on um i don't i don't really see
the difference between me and them
um
oh i'm guessing because your students
all young all healthy
even if they did get covered
they managed to recover it uh from it
quite quickly please god uh but what
about if you come into um
into contact with somebody who's older
or somebody who's frail or somebody
who's had to shelter but then is going
out on the tube for an appointment that
they have to keep what about them
so in there's always risks with
everything um you know i've personally
had quite a lot of people that have gone
into hospital and ended up dying of
hospital-borne diseases it's
it sounds really
a little bit cut throat but it's quite
normal to go into a hospital especially
when you're old and you're frail
and that's why they try to get you out
of hospital as quickly as possible
because there are hospital-borne
diseases there but for myself if i'm
testing i know i don't have covid and
i'm going in i'm healthy and i've got
antibodies then i wouldn't be any more
harm to them than someone that is
vaccinated
i i didn't quite understand what you
were saying now i'm being a bit stupid
it's thursday morning it's too early
what are you saying about elderly people
going into hospitals so that they're
pretty frail anyway so coming into
contact with health care in healthcare
you know when you've got someone that's
frail coming into hospital you do want
to get them out as soon as you can
because there are hospital-borne
diseases that's why there's pneumonia
and stuff in hospitals so in general
healthcare we've always tried to make
sure you know that they get out so that
they are safe and they are healthy
because you know hospitals are places
where people can catch things but when
you are talking about for me myself am i
at harm to them am i at risk to them
that it's the same thing i'm at the same
risk them as an unvaccinated person or a
vaccinated person because if i'm testing
and i do not have it then i can't pass
it on to them and it's the same with
someone that's vaccinated if they if
they even have the vaccine if they have
it if they get um covered they're still
gonna pass on to people and the problem
that i'm seeing is people are vaccinated
suddenly think okay i'm vaccinated now
so that makes me safer but it doesn't it
still means that they need to test it
still means that they need to wear ppe
it still means they can pass it on to
people so
there isn't much difference
but do you accept that there's less
chance of passing it on if you have been
vaccinated
i've you know i've looked at data i've
looked at the science and everything
like that and i'm
that is a possibility to be far i
haven't looked into it enough to know
the percentage of
me passing it on or someone else passing
on but the fact is if i don't have it or
if i had the antibodies
we're taking away from the fact that
most people had covered and they have
antibodies are we saying that the
vaccination is now better than what our
body naturally does that's the in in
healthcare we always try to do the you
know the least invasive treatment for
people so if someone's got antibodies
why would we then inject them with
something that's more invasive that is
generally not what healthcare does
to protect other people that they might
be sat next to on the tube who might be
well um i don't know frail or vulnerable
well if someone is for example frail and
vulnerable you know they could they
could get copied from a vaccinated
person
that's what i'm trying to say you know i
understand
the likelihood i don't i don't know the
percentages of everything but i think i
think the main the main problem the main
thing that we're seeing that people um
are upset about is the fact that we care
about people so much as healthcare
workers that we want them to live in a
world where they can choose pick and
choose what treatments they get you know
every day people come into healthcare
and they say i don't want a treatment
even though it could save their lives or
something but that's their choice and i
respect that and i love that person
regardless of what they choose to do but
we're living in a society now where
we're discriminating against people and
we're acting quite harshly towards
people that have made a decision about
their body and that's what's something
that i i don't stand for that i don't
think that's right
okay it's good to talk to you i'm so
sorry we're out of time um
let's chat again soon thanks very much
for taking the time to join us this
morning thank you that's okay bye thanks
a lot bye-bye coming up after the break
uh talking more about the energy crisis
challenges with labour stated
[Music]